[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the dave ramsey show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life
and your money i'm chris hogan and with
me today
is best-selling author and
the host of the table with anthony
o'neal mr anthony o'neill
and we are very excited to jump on the
phone with you
and talk about the things that are on
your mind now if you've got a question
about
money you've got a question about
dealing with teens and how to go to
college debt-free
dealing with student loans ao can help
you if you want to talk about
money and building wealth and retirement
i'm here for you as well
so don't hesitate pick up the phone the
phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five again
that's eight eight eight eight two five
five two two five and you can find us
online as well at ramsey's show
don't be scared to pick up the phone uh
ao i'm ready to roll are you
yeah let's go man have you had enough
caffeine uh no not yet but i'll get some
okay all right well i need you to wake
up and pep up because we have to do this
thing today hey man
are you good man this is what i do okay
all right well i know you got your show
uh the table so tell the people what
this online series the table what's it
all about
man it's simple hogan you know what i'm
saying we're having a real
relevant and relatable conversation
around money around
uh mental health around building
relationships and really breaking down
what it means to start the process of
building true wealth
because there's a huge difference
between looking like you have money and
actually having money
oh big difference and so we're just
really breaking that down for that
millennial audience
um and so it's been a great man you know
we have a new podcast launching so i'm
excited man
i really am but hey help me uh what's
the age of a millennial
well you know it's not you uh okay
what's the age of a millennial though
for real millennial age is my bracket
you know so we're inviting like
25 to about like 37 38. oh really
yeah so i told you it's not you well
that's not the point i just figured
37 38's too old to be a millennial i
yeah it's a high end you know they call
that's the upper end of a millennial oh
okay
all right well check him out uh you can
find it on all the places as anthony
said it's now available as a podcast
you can subscribe to it wherever you
listen to podcasts and uh you can also
find
anthony at anthony o'neil on instagram
youtube facebook and twitter yeah all
right we're going to the phones because
this is what we do
and first up we got julie julie is
joining us and from colorado julie how
can we help you
i am so excited to talk to you guys um
but i think my husband's going to be
more jealous
well that's okay you can you can have to
play this for him and he can listen to
it
that's right um thank you for taking my
call both of you yes ma'am
okay so um we've done
dave ish for about 10 years
yup and we have paid off
some debt and then about a month ago we
had our
we're done moment and so now we're
gazelle
intent but we're just tired because
we've been
doing it a little bit for so many years
right
and i i think my question is uh
did we screw us over you know for
wasting so many years
okay well first and foremost how old are
you
uh 40. both of you are 40. um
my husband's a little younger he's 37.
okay all right
and but before we go forward what was
the i've had at moment what what
happened
the the i've had it moment was money
issues with family members
real short my parents said they would
pay for my college
and i graduated 20 years ago and then a
month ago
my dad said i'm done with this loan
i want you guys to take it over and we
didn't know the amount
um we didn't know any information
my parents haven't talked to me about it
for
uh a good 12 years and so it just kind
of threw us through a loop
i bet how much julie how much was it
uh i don't know the original loan amount
i know that now it's
uh 42 000. my goodness
and and what's a struggle is it's
actually a
i have limited information about the
loan
um it's not in my name or my husband's
name
um but it's also
a combined loan from my mom's
schooling as well okay so i actually
don't know
um i had my own personal loan that we
have paid off
right for my college but uh this is
consolidated two loans together what's
your husband say
to this um well i said you can talk to
my dad about this
and so he called my dad because it was
too emotional for me
and he said he was not going to take out
a loan to
take over the loan but we would take on
the full payments
or as much of the payment as we can
i think for us morally
uh there's nothing written
you know there's no uh agreement with my
parents
um yeah
well here's we feel like we have to pay
it well i mean here's the deal
you know first and foremost your parents
you should have had that conversation
because what you've kind of done now is
pitted your dad
against your husband okay and so in any
kind of follow-up
any kind of follow-up information any
kind of follow-up discussion
needs to either be the both of you or
needs to come from you okay so you don't
need to make your husband the bad guy
here
i agree with you that was the initial
conversation i can imagine you being
emotional i mean
you getting hit with a forty two
thousand dollar bill that you didn't
know exists
is a terrible surprise um and and
you know so how are you all what where
are you all on the baby steps prior to
this knowledge
well we were doing the dave-ish i
understand so as you were issuing
what what baby step were you on two
okay what other debt do you all have we
have one car payment and it's
about 16 000. you got a 16 how much is
the payment
it's 380 a month okay and what's you
all's household income
uh 55 000 a year okay and and how much
is your mortgage payment
uh we're renters you're renting how much
is your rent uh
with utilities it's about 1300 a month
and how many kids you all have do you
have any one
how old four okay how are you and your
husband doing together
with this news how's your relationship
um we're good we're good it was
emotional a month ago
and now i'm looking for a job and i'm
securing daycare and we just want to
kill it we just want to plow through the
loan and
move on well this is tough and the
reason i'm asking these questions is
because you and your husband are going
to have to make a decision about what
you can do
but you need to have a conversation with
your parents as well
i would get loan verification on this
situation so you can understand
exactly how much of this debt you're
obligated for
if this is a combined situation and it's
got other loans and things piled in it
i'm not just assuming the whole thing
because he's
your dad's tired of paying it uh welcome
to the real world here buddy
we got to figure out how much it is you
actually owe and what you're responsible
for
so i would go to the company get that
verification so you can know what you're
dealing with
and and you and your husband start to
get serious on the front end of this
because what you don't want to do is to
allow this loan to get the way of the
relationship for you and your parents
right this is a bad decision made on the
front end to sign up for this thing
so here we are what do we got to do i
say it's game on
verify the loan get the facts you and
your husband buckle down
and make this thing happen and that's
the bottom line we'll be back and we'll
talk more about this after the break
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
you know healthcare has gotten to be
ridiculous
it puts people um you know on the brink
and so it would have put us on the brink
had we not had ca gm chm saved our life
same time financial lives christian
healthcare ministries or chm
is not health insurance but it is a
budget-friendly option
and the original health cost sharing
ministry for christians
learn more today and check us out at
chministries.org
that's chministries.org
[Music]
welcome back to the dave ramsey show i'm
chris hogan and
co-hosting along with me is anthony
o'neil and before we went to break we
were talking to julie
and julie's family had run into a tough
situation
uh her father and mother had taken out a
student loan
uh for her and had consolidated it with
some other loans
and then all of a sudden they contact
julie and her husband to tell them that
they're no longer going to pay for it
and so here they are with a student loan
situation that anthony
could really impact this family yeah you
know and as i was listening throughout
the call and listening to your questions
and listening to her answers
one of the key things that i'm coming
back to is communication you see
one of the things that i teach is the
breeding ground for understanding
in the ending is communication in the
beginning
and it sounds like the parents didn't
communicate this clearly with her
and so now there's confusion and i think
with her she needs to go back and have a
clear
uh sit down with her mom with her dad
and say hey you know what hey
i need understanding of what happened
what transpired
because this is it's not a possibility
this will
impact my family and i need to know
exactly
why are you coming at me with this at
the last minute and how can we have
understanding with each other moving
forward
do i need to give you ten thousand
dollars i don't think she's obligated to
the full forty thousand
but she did get an education um and i do
believe she should chip in
if she can but if she can't then the
obligation is not on her it's not on her
it's on her father
yeah well and that's why i told her you
know to do a loan verification
yes this is going back to the loan
company finding out the exact amount of
the loan
what it was so she can understand what
her portion of it is
i like the fact that her and her husband
are on the same page
you know i i do and you know julie you
were asking is it too late
no you said you had done ish baby steps
ish
and here's the thing about ish that's
really boiling down to you're not really
working it you're kind of doing your own
version of it
and what i tell people is don't do ish
do it
that means walk this process because
it'll change your financial life
there's no doubt about it and so being
on the same page together with your
spouse if you're married or if you're
single or newly single having a plan for
you
is really important but we have to make
the decision and stick to it and walk
through it
i agree anthony they do need to
communicate she does need to verify
and her and her husband need to figure
out what it is they can afford to do
and how to go about it but this is
another example and you know this all
too well
of house debt especially student loan
debt
can wreak havoc yes and i tell people
all the time we've got young people
walking into a financial aid office
signing documents they don't understand
for payments they can't afford right
and so you know this system is broken
and it's got to be fixed and
well that's why you wrote the book debt
free degree absolutely that's why i
became a number one bestseller because
there's a lot of people out there who
needed the clear path on how to do this
yeah
so all right julie thank you so much for
the call all right we're gonna go back
to the phones
uh because that's what we do here so if
you're out there and you've got a
question do me a favor pick up the phone
give us a call triple eight eight two
five five two two five
again that's 888-825-5225 we'd love to
be able to hear from you
and you can find us on the social media
at ramsey's show
all right we got rob on the line uh rob
talk to us buddy what's on your mind
hi gentlemen i hope you're having a
blessed day uh thanks for taking my call
yes sir what how can we help you today
so
actually similar to the previous caller
i was kind of ish for a couple months i
just really
kind of recently started following your
process my buddy jp really pushed
me to get onto your program was doing
ish
now fully in uh stopped my 401k
contribution sold off all my retail
investments paid off
student loans paid off the car so i am
my wife and i are officially out of debt
fantastic
how much debt did you pay off rob um
well i was fortunate in the market uh
didn't follow your guys's process
because i wasn't listening but we ended
up paying off about 30
000 in about three months fantastic
fantastic okay keep going buddy
so my question actually has to do with a
cash flow
question on we just got hit we just got
hit with some medical
and some tax bills based upon just some
things that happened we had liquidated
our savings essentially to
to follow the baby steps and now we're
essentially going we're essentially
going to liquidate our savings
again so now i'm at a position where i
want to build our savings up to three to
six months of expenses
but i'm also cash flowing my mba at
washu here in st
louis okay and i'm just trying to
understand
should from your perspective i pause
that
it's a part-time gig that i'm doing
right now
and it's costing about 900 to 1200 a
month
should i pause that even though it's
take i'm still like four years
in uh it's taking me a long time since
i'm cash flowing it
uh and our second trial is on the way
okay tell me this how much medical and
tax debt do you have
oh we don't have any it's gonna it's
gonna be wiped out by our
emergency fund no how much do you have
that you're going to be paying off
oh about 4 700 4 700 and how much do you
have in your emergency fund
about forty seven hundred dollars okay
okay so your question is
should you pause uh the mba program
while you try to build back up your
emergency fund
yes and then just the also note we'll be
saving about eighteen hundred dollars
right now is what my
the every dollar app says we'll be
saving per month
uh for towards our emergency fund so
it's 1800
and then we could be doing an additional
900 if i pause
my mb i got you okay ao what do you
thought uh rob how much are you making a
year what's your annual salary right now
uh i bring in gross 120 my wife brings
them gross
she's part-time i think close to 30.
she's a nurse
so we got about 150 uh in an income
okay you're about to pay off 4 700 in
debt as far as in some steps just came
up medical bills
but then you're paying out 900 to 1200 a
month
and for school and you're saying should
we pause it i got one quick question for
you and i want to dive into this for you
do you absolutely need this mba
right now will it will it take your 120
up to let's say like 150 160 as soon as
you get it
as soon as i get it no washu is
considered a strong school it's
considered one of the top 10 usually 15
so it's more of a long term play my main
reason of wanting to finish it is
i'm three fourths of the way through it
so i'm like 70 grams into it
yeah uh and two i am
have my second child on the way so
trying to finish it earlier than later
so they don't remember dad being away
i hear you on that one uh as far as in
time frame
how much more do you have like how many
weeks how many months do you have
left inside this program uh i've got i
think
six classes left and i'm doing one class
a semester
oh so you got a couple years yeah it's
like 20 22 before i'm done
which is why i'm wanting to why i'm
asking the question
should i pause and just further delay my
already
long mba process so for me i'm gonna
look at this two different ways all
right i don't think either side of these
are extremely wrong
i'm gonna ask myself okay if it's gonna
take me two years to finish my mba
what are the chances of emergencies
happening between now and the next two
years
there are some good opportunities some
good chances that that will come up
with you having another child on the way
and you have zero in your savings
account
what are the chances of you getting at
least 10 to 15 000
inside of your savings account within
within the next three to four months
there's a good chance of doing that if
you can honestly sit there and budget it
in
so if i'm in your shoes i am going to
pause the nba
i'm going to aggressively go ahead and
attack my emergency fund
and then i'm going to aggressively get
back in school now when i get back in
school rob
you said it's been taking you a while
i'm going to focus on make sure that i
get
there i'm saying temporarily pause
so that way you can get back into it
because i don't want you going two years
without nothing in your your emergency
fund now on the flip side
if you can go to school and get that
funded within the next six months
i'm cool with that too but for me i'm
going to focus on just going ahead and
getting 15 000
over the next 90 days inside of my
account and then jump back into school
yeah yeah i i look at this and you know
if you're able to based on your budget
right now to save
1800 you know you're talking 21 000 in a
year
that you've got saved up but you said if
you stop
uh the grad school and add that 900
along with the 1800 now you're at 2700
you could have 32
000 in your emergency fund in a year i
agree with anthony i'm pausing the
pursuit of the master's degree
uh going to get intentional about saving
that every dime to get that built up
because you're going to have life happen
yeah right you're going to be bumping up
against something
2020 taught us if it taught us anything
it taught us the need to have money set
aside because stuff comes
up and if you're bringing a new baby
into this world you know there's the
potential
of some stuff popping up so be prepared
uh it's gonna allow you to get more
focused more intentional as you move
forward
and make a difference in your life my
friend rob thank you for that call
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country or have a
better life
the army national guard can help get you
there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the show i'm chris hogan
and co-hosting along with me is
anthony o'neil and we are very excited
to take your calls about your life and
your money all you have to do is pick up
the phone kelly
is standing by and ready to help you
888-825-5225
again that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five
you can also uh find us on uh social
media at ramsay's show
and send your question in that way as
well all right next up on the line uh
we've got stephen
uh stephen is calling us from uh des
moines
stephen how can i help you
hey thanks for having me on the show
sure my friend what's on your mind
yeah i'm 26 years old i've been
saving for a house for past few years
and
my mom and dad have helped me out a lot
and just
them pay for my college but they let me
stay in their house
uh that way and make it easier for me
yes sir and um so
one way they haven't really saved much
for retirement
and one way that i thought i could help
them out
is if i could purchase their home
and the money that they'd be putting
towards their
mortgage they could put in retirement
and i was just wondering what you
thought of that idea huh hey yo
take this man stephen i really like your
heart man i can tell that you love your
parents
i can tell that you're grateful for your
parents and so i want to start off with
that by saying young man i
i i love that about you um
now answer this question are you
currently working right now stephen
yes i am okay how much are you making a
year
um my base pay is around
55 000. okay 55k a year how much debt do
you have do you
have any debt right now no not at all
okay do you have any emergency funds how
much money do you have in the bank right
now
i have around 45. 45 000
in the bank yep okay i like you brother
now you're doing good let's be real here
you're doing good i need to hear some
excitement in your voice let me ask you
this question
before before i dive in why do you want
to buy the house
outside of helping your parents out if
your parents were
not in this position okay
um if they were not in the in the
picture would you still want to purchase
this house for you
um yes and no
because i've been i've been looking at
getting an acreage
because the house they have is an
acreage it's four acres
and i want to build a machine shop and a
welding shop
okay because i do side jobs it's kind of
hard hard to do
and i didn't necessarily want to build
one if i don't own the place
on their house because it on their
property because they said
i could but i didn't really want to do
that if i was going to have to buy a
different house
you know somewhere else all right so in
that sense i would
um the problem is acreages around here
are pretty expensive
okay and with a mortgage i didn't want
to
be saddled with that for a while okay
but
the idea that i proposed to them was i
would take over the rest of their
mortgage
pay it off the money that they would put
they'd be paying for the mortgage would
go into retirement
or they'd invest it for retirement and
then
the money that i would pay them and go
to retirement too so that would kind of
give them
a leg up because they don't exactly have
that much
well hold on a second you said you would
take over the mortgage they have
yeah so where is the equity gonna go
equity i would pay
well what i would want to do my dad
talked about
taking me paying off the equity i would
pay that too
but i was thinking more of i would want
the house
revalued because what they paid for it
back then is it's worth a lot more now
okay here's so i would want to just it'd
be paying for the whole house
yeah yeah i i see what you're saying and
i want to give you
just a different perspective to consider
uh because i want to respect your
heart and your your posture for your
family
uh because i believe that is that is
very sensitive and i want to be
respectful to that
but i also want to present another
option to you because it sounds like
you're not too excited about purchasing
this house what i would do if i was you
is i would talk to your mom and dad and
say hey
how about we sell this house now okay um
and we get the equity i stephen will go
buy my house the house that
i want the house that i'm excited for
and mom and dad you just move in with me
if you want to if that's what if you're
about
you know i want my parents to live with
me i want to help them out that's fine
i just don't want to see you make a
decision and then 10 years down the road
or five years down the road you're like
i should have never done this i want you
to get into a home that you actually
love
and if you want to help your parents and
offer them a room in your house and
offer to move in with you that's fine i
think that's
totally up to you because you're in a
great position you have money your
career is doing well
you're a solid bright young man and so i
would say i would purchase the home that
i want
i wouldn't purchase the home to help out
my parents
i would do something that i want and go
from there
i do want this place i'm just i might
sound a little nervous because
i'm just talking on the phone i got your
buddy yeah i got you
so i really do like this place i grew up
i grew up on this farm so
right how many acres is this home it's
about an acre right it's four acres
four acres and how much is it worth do
you think
oh well there's my parents house and
then
my grandma has a trailer on it too
ballpark moved up from kansas with us
yeah what do you think it's worth
between 250 and 300 000 and how much do
they owe on it
i think around 60 or 70. okay
well here's another option that you have
ao i hear your option
and here's another school of thought why
don't you start paying them rent
as you're living there uh that gives
them an opportunity to be able to use
that money to attack this debt
they're 60 or 70 000 away from paying
this off
to having it outright and then they
could sell it
go find a place to rent or a smaller
place to play pay cash and use that
money
to invest to be able to grow for them um
i i don't think this is yours to solve
yeah um i i think for you young man
you've got yourself in a great position
uh now it's a matter of let them know
hey for the next nine to ten months or
nine months to 12 months i'm going to
pay you all
800 a month in rent you guys need to use
that toward attacking the house
and i think getting this thing paid off
is the better way i agree
buying this home ao this the parents are
always going to see it as their home
yeah
it doesn't matter whose name is on the
mortgage right and so i think it's just
going to put him in a situation that he
might regret later
yeah i mean you got some options there i
mean you really do
i think you got to sit back and just
figure out what is the best move
for you and with you being in a good
financial place right now
especially at the age of 26 hogan yeah i
i wouldn't see you
starting to build wealth now not trying
to bail your parents out and that may
sound wrong but i'm just like
get yourself in a good healthy position
to build
and while you're building you can be
helping a little bit but don't do so
much helping
and you're stopping yourself from
building that's what i really want to
see for you
young man that's good all right we got a
social question in real quick for ao
jared on instagram asked my wife and i
on baby step three
looking forward to babies looking
forward to baby steps four five and six
how much do you think is reasonable to
save for college our kids are one and
five
i mean one to five uh so estimating
about 10 15 years out from school
i'm going to say right now the average
school process is going to be about 100
000
for a four year in-state tuition room
and board and books
and so projecting 10 years out hogan i'm
going to up because of inflation
you're going to need about 110 to 117
depending on what
in-state school you go to uh and so i
would start anticipating
uh for that so now when you know that
ball part number
i would get with a smart vested pro and
start asking how can we invest into a
529 do we need to open up maybe another
grow stop mutual fund
how can we do something to start getting
towards that number
yeah it's imperative you know to start
to look at this and take college
seriously
uh and understand exactly where you are
there is no magic formula
on what dollar amount to invest but you
start to look at where you are
but if you are working steps four five
and six i want you to invest that
fifteen percent
i want you to definitely get intentional
about attacking the house and so you
start to look at that and that might be
two three four hundred dollars a month
that you're able to set aside again
being intentional understanding what
your goal is and like ao said
get in with the smart investor pros so
you can make sure are we on track
are we on schedule and that stuff keeps
you aware
keep your hands on the steering wheel
people your dreams are available you
just gotta drive toward them
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the dave ramsey show i'm
chris hogan and joining me
is anthony o'neil and we are excited
america
and everyone internationally that's
listening to take your call
and talk to you about your life and your
money all you have to do is pick up the
phone
triple eight eight two five five two two
five again that's triple eight eight two
five five two two five we'd love to be
able to hear from you
all right so we've been taking calls
diving in
uh and we're gonna continue with this
we've got uh john is up uh calling in
from texas john how are you
good how are you doing chris oh i'm
focused and not finished my friend
what's on your mind
um well how are you doing anthony doing
well man thanks for asking
i've got a question that i i've been
listening to dave ramsey for
probably three and a half years and i've
never really heard anything
about the rule of 55 um
on your taxes um 401k
uh my wife is 55 and she's been
at her job for over 37 years and she's
going she wants to retire
and we're going to pay the house off
that we're in now
probably by april or may so she's
waiting for that and then she'll retire
okay uh we we've been in this house for
21 years and we want to move
an upgrade she has about 280 000
in her 401k and
we'll probably need about 200 000
on top of what we sell this house for to
upgrade what we want
um so should should we take advantage of
that rule of 55
where they won't pay the 10 um penalty
to use that money to uh
pay off the house that we want to get
i've got about 800 000 in my 401k okay
good that's what i was going to ask so
all totaled right now in retirement
savings you guys are
everyday millionaires correct correct
okay so the home you're about to pay off
is worth how much
about 300. okay how many how much square
footage do you have in that house you're
in now
about a little over 2 200. okay and how
many of you are living there
well it's just me and my wife okay just
two of you okay and so how big of a
house are you trying
to buy well it's not so much
uh bigger uh maybe just a little bit but
not much but we will want just a
uh move to another neighborhood with a
swimming pool we're just
upgrading a lot of different things okay
so how big of a house do you think is in
this new neighborhood
um well it would be anywhere between
what we have now maybe in
up to 2500 square feet okay and how much
will it cost
we're thinking somewhere between 450 and
500.
okay and what's yours household income
right now
right now it's it's probably right at
200
but she makes 110
that's when she retires uh she doesn't
have a degree or anything she's just
been with this company for a long time
and she wants to take you know maybe six
months to a year off
and then find another job but she's she
doesn't think she'll
probably get anywhere between 50 and 60
000 at a new job because she doesn't
want anything
okay so stressful day so right now
you're saying
you you're pulling in about 90 000 a
year
yes okay so if i'm hearing you correctly
then walk with me here
you're wanting to sell the house you
guys are about to attack and pay off
buy a more expensive home and your
income is going to drop
by 110 000. correct
but she she will she will be getting
another job
in six to 12 months at about 50 000
right
so all right john you did all the
budgeting john in that situation i just
laid out for you
what would you do what would i do you're
gonna would you spend more
have less income coming in and go from
paid off home to now
bigger mortgage well we wouldn't have a
bigger mortgage we were thinking about
taking her uh for cashing it out yeah
no i would i'm not doing that there's no
way
there's no way i'm going to pull 200 000
out and go it's just the two of you
so you're telling me it's about this
other neighborhood in a swimming pool
join a community club like like go go
swim i'll hell i'll get you a little
portable pool
like no i'm not i'm gonna pay off this
house
and be done with that mortgage payment
freeing up that payment
and being an everyday millionaire i'm
not going to go backwards there's no
chance
no chance ayo what are you going to do
don't look at me hogan you're going to
get
riled up i i can see you know what i
mean
now let me play the devil's advocate all
right and don't come for me
all right you stay over there okay
i i hear what i hear in his voice and
you correct me if i'm wrong
this is your sweet spot what i hear in
his voice is like we just want something
a little bit better we've been working
all these years we've worked hard
we're in our older season we just want
something a little
better we've sacrificed we're everyday
millionaires we want something a little
bit better
so within that from that
bubble hogan how can they do that where
they are now
well i mean i'm gonna a i'm gonna take a
look around if i want something a little
bit different
if i pay this thing off yeah and they're
saying they're about to do that in may
yeah yeah the only way i get another
house is if i pay 100 cash for it i got
you
and so i would find a better
neighborhood but i'm going to find a
cheaper house in that neighborhood so i
can
take this 300 000 from this home that's
very clear yeah
and i'm going to go buy a house for 250.
yeah you know what i mean
i can't i ca i can't fathom going
backwards okay now if they really love
this neighborhood
let's say all their friends in that
neighborhood and their hearts are happy
and everybody's holding hands and
skipping and singing kumbaya
and this is the place you got to live
then guess what honey let's work another
year
of you making 110 i'm gonna kick it into
high gear and get a second job
and we're gonna have this extra we're
gonna get another 125 000
saved up and we're going to pay sell our
house for cash
get 300 we're going to use this money
that we've saved for another year
and we're going to go to this
neighborhood that is shangri-la
and i'm going to be debt-free no no no i
like that i like that hogan because i
mean i
i i heard him in his voice like just my
wife we worked so hard
we went i feel like they they want a
brand new kitchen they
you know they want a bigger a bigger bed
here's another thing here's another
thing you could do
if you're tired if you you like the
house yeah and you just say boy i just
would like something different
cash flow some renovations that's a good
option you know yeah
but if they if that's the neighborhood
i'm going to work another year or two or
whatever i just can't go backwards
now i'm now going to get riled up
because we're talking about pulling
money out of the 401k
you're going from an everyday
millionaire you're going to go backwards
pulling 280 000 out
i don't care about the rule of 55 this
money was put there so you all could
secure your financial future
yeah you you're gonna erase the years of
deposits
from this one withdrawal form there's no
chance i'm doing that
not for a home and it's just two of you
right i mean i might even downgrade you
guys might decide you want to take trips
and you want to travel some places
and do some things uh that i'm fine with
but i want to cash flow it and be
intentional i'm with you i'm still
trying to think about what
i mean just what just wave your head at
me sir out here in the lobby
uh if you're 60 are you swimming in your
pool every day yes or no
see see i'm trying to figure out why why
do they win a pool well they want to
swim what's wrong with that but you're
going to spend a lot of time
but you're going to spend a lot of money
to just have a pool in the backyard you
ain't swimming every day well they don't
make floaters my size but listen
the bottom line is you're right but but
but and there's nothing wrong with
enjoying
and i'm saying there's nothing wrong
these people obviously have worked hard
they've become everyday millionaires
it's not an accident
but i i just again i would be more
willing to work another couple years
right
uh just so i go in and go we can't go
backwards yeah like we've come too far
and now with that home paid off if we
decide we want to take a trip to europe
or we want to decide to do something i
mean if you want to swim that bad
pay off this house and put a pool in
your house i like it right
i mean again i think there are options
john is what i'm saying buddy
and what you hear is i'm a little riled
up because i've been hearing the numbers
of people that have been pulling money
out of their 401k
and they're erasing all those years of
deposits and growth
and they're going to look back on it in
about five or six years and they're
going to say oh wait
what did i do i'm going to have to work
seven eight more years to make up
for that one hour of not thinking
clearly
and so you all have been so intentional
brother stay the path
like i want you to have that mindset of
i'm not going backwards
not for a pool not for anything we're
gonna pay this house off
wait about four to six weeks and get
that deed in your hand and i want you to
look at it
this is the thing you've worked hard for
typically people are paying on the
paying off their homes or paying on them
for around 30 years
you've got a chance to be different
brother and to start
a new legacy for you as well as your
family so
i hope you and your wife sit down and
think about it be st be clear
your dreams are available you just got
to make the right choice
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car
rental studio this is the dave ramsey
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money
i'm chris hogan and co-hosting along
with me this hour is anthony o'neil
and we are very excited to be back with
you
and we're ready to take your call so
what i want you to do is pick up the
phone and give us a call
kelly's standing by and ready to take
your question the number is triple eight
eight two five
five two two five again that's
two five or 888-825-5225 can find us at
the ramsey show
ayo i'm ready to roll you ready hey man
let's get it man i'm happy about this
hour happy to be on this show with you
and uh some amazing people in the lobby
as well yeah nope we're excited and we
can't wait to take your call so we're
gonna jump on there but before we do
this
you know people are talking to me all
the time about how this year
is that year of reset we're coming out
of 2020
which was a crazy year uh we dealt with
a lot of stuff we had
weather issues we had the pandemic uh we
had some probably some crazy people
around us
that were having to deal with ao you got
any crazy people in your world i got a
lot of them
okay yeah so you got to be aware so what
do we got to do well we've got to reset
this thing
so you've got an opportunity to hit
reset no matter what happened last year
you can take control of your money today
and ramsay plus can help you
with our money reset bundle it's easier
than ever to create a new life
of habits and habits are huge the bundle
includes get this a six-month
membership to ramsey plus plus our
best-selling books
know yourself know your money and the og
the original the total money makeover uh
and here's the kicker
every ramsey plus membership now
includes a ramsey smart tax
federal classic e-file so you've got an
opportunity to get your taxes done as
well
so you can get your money right and you
can get your taxes right
this is a value of 167
but you're going to get it now for 85
bucks
you kidding me people spend more than
that just to get taxes done
sure do so check out ramsey plus decide
on a total money reset right now
uh small steps can lead to big changes
so go
to moneyresetbundle.com again you get
this bundle go to
moneyresetbundle.com and you've got a
great opportunity for those folks that
are watching on the youtube channel you
can see the link right below
uh excuse me the the graph right there
moneyresetbundle.com you've got a great
opportunity to make this your account
we want it 2020 gone guess what it's
gone
2021 is here so let's make sure we make
it count all right we're going to get to
the phones
uh and find out what's on the mind we
got glenn collin from north carolina
glenn how are you
hey chris how you doing buddy oh i'm
focused or not finished my friend what's
on your mind today
well i just kind of tried to make it a
short question
uh i retired august 28
at age 59. i
turned 60 september 22nd
the company i worked for for 32 years
uh come out with a service package
restructuring their their company and
i decided to take it and one reason with
that
is i was kind of getting tired of the
millennial age and i don't hope i don't
spend nobody there
yeah but i'm kind of old school
and i took it and basically got
a 248 thousand dollar service check
when i've checked but gross money yes
sir
oh they all they also
paying my health insurance for 18 months
100
okay uh after that and also
are providing me 500 a month
24 months after that to offset
uh health insurance coverage all right
you know until i reach 65.
yes sir and i also
i've just had a settlement several
months ago with
north carolina d.o.t buying my house
because of a highway road project
of large sump money well tell me that
you don't told me everything else
what's the chunk how much six
six six hundred forty two thousand three
hundred dollars all right
go ahead and out of that
i had to pay off my mortgage yes sir you
know that all comes into
you know calculations a long story short
net monies out of that and net money
from my servants uh
i have paid every debt off
i have purchased a new home cash
should i don't i don't owe anybody
a dime all right so how much did you
have left over
478 or 79 pounds you are
on the ball brother all right i like i
like where you're going what's your
question
all right my main concern is did i
retire too early
okay all right well what were you making
per year at that job that you worked 32
years at
about 132 000 okay
all right so as i look at this you got
about two years worth
okay of that you took this money
and how much did you have a 401k with
that company at all
i did how much you got in that 401k
i took i removed it all from the company
and
reinvested it with a financial advisor
how much which was
a total uh between the
401k and extra money from d.o.t
was about 3.98 okay and i have about
420 in it now which okay from
september now all right no you did the
absolute right thing
you're an everyday millionaire my friend
you don't owe anybody on your house
you've got 400 000 that's in invested in
your 401k
you got 478 000 left over in cash right
now
so what i would do is pluck about 30 000
over for an emergency fund
take that other 440 000 i'm gonna get
that with an investment professional
so now assets under advisement and
what's being
invested is eight hundred thousand
dollars you're good to go
you don't owe anybody a dime uh glenn
no you you you're good here's the other
thing you can decide to work more if you
want to
right doesn't mean you have to go back
with that company you can go find a job
or do something he did the right thing
yeah he did the right thing the only
thing you said wrong was that you was
offended by some of us millennials
oh listen to you you know what i'm
saying we ain't do nothing wrong
we trying to work too listen come on now
listen i'm happy i'm happy with what he
did listen but you can't be blaming us
millennials because we out here working
too
okay see you you you just threw shaded
me about my age not long ago and uh
i'm taking the shade but i'm just saying
you know you can't be coming at us like
that
glenn is glenn was just trying to be
honest and i'm being honest
okay maybe some people are flopping
around at flip flops while he's got on
work boots he's trying to handle
business
uh glenn i'm mad at glenn no i'm proud
of you buddy um
and you know you being intentional and
being smart what you do moving forward
can set you up or set you back
and i mean what i mean by this is your
home is paid for you paid off all the
debts
what you got to do is avoid doing any
stupid glenn
and i'm telling you it's on every corner
so don't let your guard down
if you're going to do something do it
with cash but no more debt in your life
man you got freedom
now what i want you to do is enjoy it
and build a legacy
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters
with easy online ordering free shipping
and a guaranteed perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Music]
so
welcome back to the dave ramsey show i'm
chris hogan and co-hosting along with me
is anthony o'neil and we are having a
blast
talking to you about the things that are
on your mind uh pick up the phone and
call us
triple eight eight two five five two two
five again that's eight
eight eight two five five two two five
uh we'd love to be able to hear from you
about the things that are on your mind
and as we pursue progress that's one of
the things i talk about
on the chris hogan show is that it's a
matter of being intentional
and we've got to make decisions every
day that put ourselves in a position to
be able to make progress
and ao you obviously have the book out
debt-free degree and you you have been
very intentional about helping people in
this process
uh but you also have a show called the
table
and you got new episodes that air every
monday uh you talk about how to set a
clear vision for your future
so you can start winning with your life
your money and your relationships yes
um wow that clear vision is something a
lot of people need
yeah yeah clear vision uh for your life
for your money and for your
relationships and what i'm really
excited about when it comes to
uh the table hogan is that we really get
down and have some real
relevant and relatable conversations
prime example this week in honor of
black history month
uh we brought back my black history
panel and how gonna be real
and there are some things on there that
are said by these individuals that's
going to challenge you
and me and dave was talking about it
yesterday here on the show and i want to
encourage everyone right now whether you
black white hispanic you name it
go check out the show and you know what
you're gonna hear some things that you
may not agree with
but i love hearing different
perspectives and different
thoughts so we can just understand in
honor of black history month how some
people are thinking
but i love because this is bringing in
people and when they get to my content
they're learning how to
you know what have the uncomfortable
conversations around money how to
really start building healthy
relationships but this week is gold it
is crucial
i would encourage everyone if you're on
youtube or if you'd like to listen on
podcasts while you're walking or jogging
or doing things around the house or in
the car uh go download it on apple
podcast
uh but you want to see our facial
expressions man because my facial
expressions are
amazing oh i mean they're so amazing
well they're that
yes there's that okay well i've pictured
you a stoic
i didn't realize that you had those
expressions of course you do
you're lively dude you're expressive uh
yeah check out that show
again you can find it anywhere where you
subscribe to listen to podcasts
uh also on youtube uh you can find him
at anthony o'neil
and uh so opportunity you know growth
awareness
uh and you just had matthew mcconaughey
on your show right i did
i did just interviewed him and it was a
lot of fun
i got a chance to really dig in and find
out about his new book called green
lights yeah
which really came from years of him
journaling and uh he's an interesting uh
individual his mindset uh very focused
very intelligent very articulate
uh so yes if you've not had a chance to
check that out go over on youtube
uh the chris hogan show and you can kind
of watch that interview
and uh dig in uh it's interesting and of
course he is iconic with
his words and phrases we had a great
conversation uh ao you had a chance to
talk to him as well
yeah and dig in and uh you were really
talking to him about his
journey to success yes man that was
crucial because most young people want
to become
famous and i really wanted to have the
conversation around hey
do you regret any decisions when you was
building your fame
he said yes yeah no he was real so
anyway check those out you can find it
on youtube
under anthony o'neil or chris hogan 360
you can see it
all right listen we're getting to the
phones this is what we do
and so uh we got william on the line
from texarkana
i've never been there william how are
you buddy
you know what y'all gonna stop coming
for us millennials on this show okay
william you are my favorite caller my
friend
what's on your mind today buddy well i
think you folks talking about how
paying interest is a bad thing okay
getting interest is a good thing
yeah and then you talk about compounding
okay i do not understand compound
interest i don't know how it works and i
want an education today
all right well you know what it's one of
those things where you look at it
and i i look at this way that that it's
interest earned on money that was
previously earned as interest
now i know that sounds like double speak
but as you look at this william you put
money in interest
can work for us or against us right as
you know if you pay it it's a penalty
if you earn it it's a reward and so the
compound interest the compound growth
that happens from that is the thing that
truly
allows us to be able to grow money and
so
looking at it understanding if i put
money in it's growing interest
now guess what happens this whole thing
that is in there that's now bigger
is now going to grow more interest and
that's the factor that causes our 401ks
and 403s
three b's to grow exponentially as well
as our roth iras
and other things so that investing money
is imperative because we all know the
dollar
shrinks each year and what i mean by
that is the cost of living that happens
inflation app in the marketplace and so
we've got to grow
our money and william i'll tell you what
i'm going to do i'm going to send you my
book i talked about being a money boss
in my book retire inspired the first
book i wrote i'm going to send you a
copy of that
and because you said focused and not
finished
i'm going to throw in a focused and not
finished sticker in there
for you my friend so i appreciate the
call again compound interest is interest
earned on money that was previously
earned as
interest and that's how it grows buddy
and if we leave money alone
and not listen to the cares act and not
listen to these other things that are
out there
and leave money in our 401ks and 403bs
it will grow
thank you for that kelly's going to get
your information like i said i'm going
to send you a signed copy of retire
inspired
and a focus and not finished sticker hey
kelly pretty cool kelly send him a
picture of me too just so he can see a
millennial smiling at him as well please
y'all coming for us millennials oh no i
love millennia listen hey believe it or
not
i've had several millennials calling on
my show yes
that have either gone through
foundations yes but they've listened to
it ao i'm talking to millennials that
have fifty
and a hundred thousand dollars saved oh
yeah uh two hundred thousand
one told me they just paid off their
house at 27.
good guy yeah so i love millennials
i do i really do say that again i love
millennials thank you i do
and so anyway i just i especially focus
on not finished
once people that are driving forward on
stuff so here's the
deal if you are a a baby boomer yeah
traditionalist do you even know what a
traditionalist is yeah traditional and
modern relationships right
no ao traditional somebody that's 60 or
older
see you don't even know this okay if
you're a traditionalist baby boomer gen
y
gen x gen z or millennial you all get a
chance to make a decision about our
futures
we all do i'ma google that yeah google
it you got your little fancy pad over
there google it
but listen we all have a chance to make
a decision about our futures
and that's one of the things we've done
here at ramsey solutions as we're
talking to people helping them
understand that there's hope in your
business there's hope
in your dealing with your money there's
hope in dealing with your relationships
but we get to decide and i know there
are people out there that have opinions
i know there are people out there that
are throwing shade there's a drink for
haters people it's called haterate
and and that's just real the bottom line
is is we get to choose
and i want us to choose for our future
ayo one of the things i've been telling
people is to make two-year decisions
and what i mean by that is make a
decision today that you're going to look
back on in two years and you're glad
that you made it
oh man that's so gold hogan because you
know my statement that i live by every
single day
is that the caliber of our future will
be determined by the decisions the
choices
we make today yes no they're what you're
saying yeah
for two years and when those two years
come make another decision
for the next two years and eventually
your future is going to be brighter and
much better no you're absolutely right
it helps us pull up
out of our situation that's good and and
it helps us think a little bit clearly
all right we're about to go to break
here in just a few but listen here's one
of the things we're going to do
i'm going to ask anthony o'neil i want
to know what was the best piece of
advice
he ever got from one of his grandparents
best piece of advice
because i'm going to share with you mine
and the thing that was a game changer
for me
uh for first and foremost it was my
grandmother told me
honey understand the difference between
an opportunity and a chance
she said an opportunity leads you
somewhere but a chance is 50 50.
and it's one of those things that i
never forgot
thinking about that opportunity versus
chance chance is 50 50.
it's like a coin toss right might be
heads it might be tails
but an opportunity when you do it it
leads you somewhere gets you closer
and that's exactly what we do here at
ramsey solutions we give you an
opportunity to have a different
financial future when we come back i'm
going to ask anthony
the best piece of advice he got from his
grandparents don't go anywhere
hold on this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs
and the ability to negotiate medical
costs down established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the dave ramsey show i'm
chris hogan and posting on with me is
anthony o'neil
and we are taking your calls about your
life and your money
before we went to break i told you about
the best piece of advice i got from my
grandparents
uh my grandmother told me the difference
between opportunity and chance
that you want to grab opportunities you
don't avoid the chances
do the thing that sets you up for your
future and as we went into break i told
ao
that when we came back i wanted to hear
the best piece of advice he had received
from his grandparents
now grandparents are full of all kinds
of wisdom and amazing things but what
was that one piece of advice
uh oh do you really want to know the
truth yes
my grandmother my grandmother said son
make sure you marry a woman and not a
little girl
in a woman's body oh and
what she was saying was and she broke it
down because i was like what what do you
mean
she said sometimes i want you to make
sure that you are a man
and you're not operating with the little
boy's mindset
you know because when you were a child
you spoke as a child but when you become
a man
be a man and so that was one of the best
piece of advices my grandmother
ever gave me because ever since then
have i made all the right decisions no
but i do ask myself am i making a manly
uh in my spiritual faith a man of god
decision here
am i walking in integrity am i walking
with character
and am i gonna and in my dating process
you know am i dating a woman with
integrity
am i dating a woman with character um
and are we both
operating in who we are or are we still
thinking and acting like little kids
very good
no that's wise and again you know
grandparents they're always they've got
amazing wisdom
and i'm so grateful for the time spent
on that front porch and that back porch
uh and in the garden and all the other
places uh it's just amazing
and you know i'd encourage you if you
haven't written down some of those
pieces of information
or wisdoms or little sayings your
grandparents used to tell you
get those things written down uh put
those in a place i'm lucky enough to
have some things that were
uh done by needlepoint by mama hogan uh
and some statements and stuff by my
grandparents that is that that are
logged
and i can share with my boys as well so
all right let's get back to the phones
uh the number to call in is eight two
eight eight eight eight two five five
two two five
again that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five we'd love to hear from
you
or you can find us on social media at
ramsey show all right next up
we got uh nicole is on line three nicole
how can we help you
hi anthony and chris um i am
a distinguished millennial yes um i
am 35 and i have fifty three thousand
dollars saved yes and i am very likely
pregnant
yes um so it's very early and
next week i have an appointment and um
so this will be my second baby and i'm
struggling because i have seventy three
thousand dollars
in student loan debt and i'm not sure if
i should put that money towards the
student loan
or start saving for the hospital bills
and doctor bills because i don't have
insurance
and i got a quote that it'll be between
10 to 22 000
depending on how the labor goes okay so
i just want to know
i'm kind of new to this i don't really
know what what to do with the money
hey hogan i got this this is for
millennials calm down oh man um
uh i want to say amen i i love this you
just made my day
and uh so all right so let's start back
from the beginning how much money do you
have in the bank account again
um i sorry my toddler's at the door but
um
i have fifty three thousand saved okay
all right we got fifty three seventy
three thousand in debt
okay cool and then when are you due
well i if i'm pregnant then it will be
nine nine almost ten months from now
okay so so we don't know it we don't
know if you're pregnant just yet but
you're just saying if you are pregnant
uh what i'm very likely pregnant i'll
just say that without being uncoached
i got you hey i'm with you you know your
body so i'm gonna shut up and go ahead
and give you this advice that you called
in for
um here's here's the priority okay your
priority is delivering the baby
healthy and making sure that you stack
enough
money to deliver the baby and then i
always say add a little bit of cushion
in there
just to make sure if there are any other
emergencies or anything like that
do i think you need fifty three thousand
dollars to uh have a a safety net for a
baby
no i don't you know i now never had a
baby hogan's had a few of them
but i would say maybe set aside about
fifteen to twenty thousand dollars
okay in an emergency account for that
but then i would start attacking
the seventy three thousand dollars and
if you let's say for an example you know
what anthony i want some real good
cushion
put twenty five thousand dollars to the
side and then take the other twenty what
seven
twenty eight thousand dollars put that
towards the twenty the seventy three
thousand dollars that you have in debt
and then attack it now i'm pretty sure
you're not gonna use all 25
000 of that so about a month so a month
or so after you have the baby
take the rest that you have that you
have saved up and put that towards the
debt but
you're doing very very good now what's
this 73 000
in debt though is it student loans cars
what is it
it's all student loans for me all of
them so you don't have any credit card
payments no
no car loans nope nothing else
okay cool great yeah so right now here's
a good thing
uh these are federal or private loans
just kind of federal okay cool so right
now you're not paying any interest all
right
and so right now is a great time to go
ahead and put this money on top of it
so this way you can pay off some stuff
without curing any penalties on that
side of things but
that's what i would say on my end for
you is to create
a safety net for you and your baby um
and then after that
once you create the little small safety
net which you already have it go ahead
and tap the 73 thousand dollars
okay so i can make a payment after i
save the 25
ish yes well you already have the 25.
yeah yeah right so then the rest will
pay towards the
loan okay i just didn't know what to do
first it's like a lot of money and i'm
scared
yeah yeah the right subject now do you
still have income coming in though are
you still working right now
i do my husband makes 60 a year and i
make about 40.
yeah and i'm at home i might lose my job
if i
get sick and can't do it but yeah yeah
25 000 i think is more than enough hogan
is that would you say yeah i do and i i
like the mindset you know you look at
this and you realize
73 000 is a lot in student loan debt 53
000 a lot saved yes and so to be able to
to make that
that that that payment to be able to
attack it and to
look up and only have 20 1
000 in student loan debt there's a
massive jump
and a great improvement and you know i i
think nicole you're going to put
yourself
on a path of being more intentional and
focused
and you want to you want to keep that
mindset as you're moving forward
uh because that that's what's going to
allow you to make a difference
in your financial future without a doubt
uh looking at this i also i want to let
you know
uh paying off that smart and saving and
investing is also smart
but there's one key to winning with
money that's often forgotten and that's
protecting your family
from emergencies there are ten kinds of
insurance coverage
that you might need based on your life
situation and instead of you trying to
figure it out we've built a tool
that'll show you what coverage you need
what to drop
or what needs to be adjusted and get
this it takes
five minutes people so we're even give
you a to-do list by rank of importance
and email it to you so you can get
started on the on the process of getting
it done fast
it's called a coverage checkup and it
could be the most important five minutes
that you spend today
uh donald h wrote in and said i like how
he put it
he said for anyone who's not completed
this checkup do it
now you never know when something will
happen and you'll never be able to
you never want to leave your family in a
bad situation
so get out your phone right now and text
the word checkup
no spaces no dashes just check up to
33789
or you can visit daveramsey.com check up
today
don't let an emergency sneak up on you i
want you to protect your family
right now ao i talk all the time about
building wealth about becoming an
everyday millionaire you're helping
millennials
understand their path and their root we
got to protect it too
yes and insurance is exactly what you
need
and i want to remind people out there
you know if you're a homeowner you've
definitely got home insurance homeowners
insurance because you want to protect
the home
if you're a renter you need renters
insurance yes because you can protect
your stuff
car insurance is in invaluable and you
know the granddaddy of them all
is life insurance absolutely and here's
the thing that i learned with uh
millennials uh hogan four out of ten
millennials do not have the correct
coverage wow life insurance yeah so you
want to get term life
insurance get it 10 to 12 times your
annual income
and and i'm telling you it's how you say
i love you to your family
protect yourself people build wealth but
let's also protect it
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everyone this is the dave
ramsey show hey
on the last call we were talking to a
young lady and she was
uh nicole from eugene oregon and she was
talking about having a chunk of money
saved in that situation
for the birth of a baby which we always
tell people yes you definitely want to
stockpile some money but i got a message
on social media and someone said
well what if you don't have health
insurance what would you do
well if you don't have health insurance
you are definitely stockpiling money
because
you know a trip to the nicu uh you know
a a prolonged stay there or any kind of
health situation for the mom
or the baby uh can be a financial
devastation
so you would definitely in that
situation if you had money stockpiled
you're going to keep that money
stockpiled until you get that baby home
and then from there when everything is
okay and stabilized
then you know what to deal with as you
move forward and so that's the reality
of what you're doing that in that
hypothetical situation so
i want to thank the person for reaching
out to me on social media with
that question all right we're going back
to the phones uh we got ginger on the
line ginger
how are you i'm good chris how are you
oh i'm focused and not finished i'm here
hanging out with
with a distinguished millennial uh how
can i help you
awesome hey thanks for taking my call so
i found you guys a little bit later in
life
um so i've done things a little bit out
of order i'm 41
i'm a single mom of two i'm working on
baby step three so i don't have any uh
consumer debt or anything like that
um i do have a mortgage i'm in a 20-year
fixed right now
at a three and a half percent so i've
been paying that for i don't know i
think i have 17 years left
um i owe about 320 000 on my home yes
ma'am um i have
about 165 000 in a 401k
um so again totally out of order i don't
have anybody in the bank per se
or at least not much but i have that in
a 401k
um so my big question is i bought this
house a few years ago knowing that it
would need repairs
over time but these things are like
starting to come up like
my basement flooded a couple of years
ago i had to sell my car and pay for
that
um just things are starting to come up
like big repairs on this house
um a little faster than i thought what
are some of the big repairs ginger
yeah so um i i have some siding on the
side of my house that is blowing a
little bit and i
um i i worry that it is a water issue
and that's what actually caused the
basement um
so that's which i think you know may
start in my attic and it's coming down
the side of my house
that's the big one also um i live right
off of a field so it's a beautiful
house like i don't want to get rid of it
um it's already grown in equity it's now
worth like about 415 000
so um it's you know appreciating for
sure
but you know it's right off the field so
there have been some issues with some
mice and like some other i mean just
problems like okay so are those the two
big things
yeah well it's also everything is
original to the home so it's like
builder's grade
plumbing you know the toilets the
plumbing is not
great um you know everything's original
of the house
yeah so those would be yeah they're
basic items so those
those would be upgrades those aren't
serious repairs
okay right i mean i'd say some of them
are not serious repairs in the basement
obviously basement was serious
absolutely how long ago did you buy this
home
uh about three years ago okay did you
get a property inspection done
i did okay go ahead
yeah sorry there were a lot of to do's
on that and i've gotten i'd say some of
them done
okay all right and and the reason i'm
asking that ginger because number one as
a single mom of two
you're working hard you're taking care
of business i i always want people
to be aware of the difference between a
want and a need yeah
okay and and again i know stylistically
there can be some things about the house
that you're like oh no
as soon as you saw that that sink you
knew you were gonna upgrade
it at some point right or you saw that
light fixture and you're like not up in
my house
i'm getting rid of that and and again
it's great to have that to-do list but
what i don't want you to do is confuse a
want versus a need
okay this the basement you're absolutely
right that was that's ridiculous
uh but but now as you look at the siding
yeah you want to find out
is this a water issue because that could
lead to a bigger one
but i don't want you to try to jump the
gun
um and the reason i say that is you're
the prime target
for a mortgage lender or a bank to try
to offer you a home equity line of
credit
okay they will try to rationalize and i
am a reformed banker
i'm an rb okay you don't want to go that
route you don't want to treat your home
like an atm
where you're pulling money out your home
is your largest monetary asset for you
and your kids
young lady and so the last thing you
want to do is borrow against it
now saving up to prepare things that are
necessary
yes but determine a want versus a need
nah man you're hitting him right on
hogan i i i
don't need to say anything after that
bro you did a good job well
and ginger and just take your time you
know
take your time yeah how much uh what are
you you're making how much are you
making a year
um about 108 okay okay
and are you able to work from home or
are you working outside of the home
um it's kind of a little bit of both
that's good i'm a field rep
yeah so i can work a couple days from
home yeah um you know i have windows
coming in in a couple
couple weeks i'm only doing the top
floor for now because that's all i can
afford but
yeah um the windows like when the wind
comes through here the whole house like
vibrates and whistles and shakes i mean
it's crazy so well and you're in
you're out in colorado so wind is real
out there
but listen i hope you're plugged in with
a good church
uh if you are i want you to reach out
find somebody there
that's good with repairs or good with
homes or know someone that is someone
reputable
have them come out check your attic uh
check the flashing on your on your roof
too
look at me i'm using builder terms you
don't know about this ao
you want to check the flashing to see if
water's getting in
uh and if there's any structural issues
so look at your home
uh that inspection report uh have
someone come out and look
uh it could be a you know a lady or a
male that's certified to be able to
inspect that and be honest with you
about what's going on prioritize those
repairs
and then take a deep breath the upgrades
and the things that you want to do
absolutely you're going to be able to
get to those but in due time
and so just set up a plan for yourself
and then give yourself the opportunity
to work toward that goal love it hogan
yeah i have some good advice
yeah that's rough man because you know
you just moved recently i did
and when you move in you have a vision
absolutely but you know what i still
haven't done everything i want i haven't
done 50
of the things that i wanted because i
got to go buy priorities and i got to
move at the speed of cash
um i have other priorities that are more
important than upgrading
but now if something did happen if like
my siding was starting to come and it
would come off and it was because of
you know some watering issues then yes
i'm fixing that because that's
structural damage
eventually uh but as far as like right
now i want to upgrade all my light
switches to smart switches oh that's not
a priority you know yeah uh so for me
because i'm a millennial um i like
technology stuff but as a wise
millennial i know i need to stick to
priorities and stick to cash flowing
yeah no
you're absolutely right moving at the
speed of cash imperative here's another
thing to check into ginger
that siding issue if that happened from
when
you might want to reach out and talk
once you find out what the issue is
you may want to reach out to your your
homeowner's insurance
uh to find out if this is something that
is covered and again so it's going to
require some research and some reaching
out
but then you're not guessing and what i
know to be
factual is little things on the back of
your brain
until you get the right information it
can nag at you
right and the next thing you know it's
just getting bigger and it's getting
bigger
uh so thank you so much for that call
speaking of i got someone they uh
reached out to us on social media and
said hey
i've just become debt free i'm newly
debt-free do i need this from brianna
from facebook
newly debt-free do i need to adjust my
insurances car insurance homeowners
et cetera now that i don't owe any money
brianna that's a great question
absolutely you do now that you're debt
free
if you have your emergency fund you
don't tell me if you have that or not
but now that you're debt-free great job
get your emergency fund in place
you want three to six months of expenses
saved up to protect you
once you do that you can contact your
homeowners
your car insurance all of those and
raise your deductible
yeah what that's going to do is that's
the amount you would pay out of pocket
if there was a loss
what that's going to do is drive down
how much you're paying
monthly you see what i'm doing you're
going to take on more of the risk
because you've got
cash now with that emergency fund listen
thank you all for tuning in i want to
thank producer james childs and
associate producer kelly daniel
and i want to thank all of you for
tuning in this has been
the dave ramsey show
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the dave ramsey show
broadcasting from the dollar car rental
studio where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life
and your money i'm chris hogan and
co-hosting along with me this hour is
anthony o'neil
and i can't tell you how excited we are
to have a conversation with you
so if you're out there and you've got a
question about
dealing with student loans dealing with
family members and money
or you want to build wealth you want to
get out of debt you want to get more
serious
this year about your money than you ever
have before then this is the show to
call
i want you to pick up the phone and give
us a shout 888-825-5225
again that's triple eight eight two five
five
two two five we are ready to talk to you
all right ao you ready for this
man let's do it man all right all right
listen we're gonna go to the phones
because that's what we do
anthony and i both have a lot of words
and we're willing to talk to you and
help you
ao's got more than me but we want to
help you and get to where it is you want
to go
so we're going to get on the line here
we got lindsay calling in from denver
lindsay how are you how are you how are
you
oh we're focused and not finished what's
on your mind today
um so my husband and i are 27 and 28.
millennials yes very much so
um three years ago we decided to
downgrade our lifestyle
and move into a motorhome to live in an
rv with our four children
and we've been able to pay off all of
our debt and we still
owe 22 000 on the rv but we
um get as a mortgage and we pay double
what we're supposed to every month
so my question for y'all is we
um have sixteen thousand dollars in our
savings
fifteen hundred dollars in our main and
we can save twenty seven hundred dollars
a month
my question is in six months we're gonna
have thirty thousand dollars more
what do i do with that okay so other
than paying off my army that's an
obvious
okay so outside is the rv the only loan
you have
it's literally the only thing we pay on
okay and so
well hold on you said pay on now lindsay
you're throwing me a curveball here
is that the only debt you have yes
okay all right because people have debt
they just don't pay on it so that's why
i'm double checking
uh what's going on what's y'all's
household income
thousand um a year what's he do for a
living
he's a top runner he's a what owner
a pot fitter oh a pipe fitter okay got
you
and so um so are you all traveling in
this rv
or is just living in it so my husband
was in the military and he's currently
in an apprentice program
that the military pays for his school
and so as soon as he graduates in may
will be able to travel which is the plan
to chase the powerhouses
to make even more money and i just want
to get a handle on the money that we're
making now so that way when we are
making
half a million dollars in a year we'll
be able to yes
be able to move forward yes ma'am so
lindsay are y'all comfortable with
living in this
rv with your four kids like honestly
um so i'm a minimalist and i have very
few things
my children kind of follow suit in that
i homeschool them and i have
since they were little so i personally
really enjoy
the everyone together lifestyle of
course i would love to have
a big house and all those things back in
arkansas where i'm from
but right now my family that my husband
and i made is more important than
having a house and having debt and all
those types of things so
good hey what are the ages of the kids
uh nine six three and two oh wow okay
ooh
you're busy you guys are busy well
now well i i you know i'm all i talk to
people on the chris hogan show about
making sacrifices
for stuff that you're serious about and
you guys definitely did that
yeah you sold your house you're living
in an rv with the four kids
you're homeschooling your husband is a
pipefitter right now
that's in an apprenticeship um so you
said what do you do with the money you
got
16 000 saved up and you owe 22 000 on
this rv
here's the reality right okay point
blank lindsay you are going to want to
pay off this rv
yeah like yeah get this thing paid off
but here's the other thing you're going
to need an emergency fund
asap because you're you're you're
driving your home
right so i mean you know anything that's
drivable has repairs
homes have repairs so you guys will want
to be
very intentional after you pay it off
about being
intentional with the budget to build up
that emergency fund you three to six
months of expenses
that way if there is a repair or
something that's necessary you got the
money to handle it
yeah and i wouldn't commend her you know
i'm not i'm not a huge fan of rvs i'm
gonna be real
just to live in them but i hear her
heart i hear her purpose
right and i can respect that yes you
know what i'm saying i can rock with
that like hey
yeah one day i want to have this but i
want to make some sacrifices with my
family and
i'm a minimalist so i love living in
small
spaces so i agree with you hogan pay off
the rv
stack up this money and then enjoy your
future but eventually
you are you will need a house yeah with
teenagers and you follow the baby steps
so you've got your fully funded
emergency fund
you guys are going to after that's in
place you're going to want to start
investing 15
toward retirement then you guys are
going to start saving for college for
these fees for the four kids
and you know you're going to just be
putting money away in that realm
when you get ready to buy a home you
want to do a 15 year fixed rate mortgage
uh i'd love for you to put 20 down but
10 is okay
yeah you don't want to get a payment
that's more on your mortgage more than
25
of your take-home pay and so you
following through the plan young lady is
going to put you all on the path
now lindsay i don't know if y'all have a
tv or not uh
you said you're minimalist but if you've
got access to the internet i i want to i
want to gift you ramsay plus
i want to put you all give you an
opportunity kelly will get your
information
you guys can plug in uh inside of ramsay
plus you're going to get a lot of things
you're going to be able to you utilize
every dollar
the best budgeting tool on the planet
you're going to be able to use the debt
tracker so you're going to be able to
track when you guys are going to pay off
this rv
when it becomes yours for sure and
you're going to get guidance from me
about investing you're going to get
guidance from from all of us about
different areas of life
so ramsay plus go check you're going to
be able to check it out for free
those of you that are out there
listening you go well i want to be
involved i want to
check it out go to ramseyplus.com yeah
just ramsay plus
ramsayplus.com
you can check it out and see all the
benefits and all the things that are
going on
you know what hogan talking about you
know ramsay plus and and we've
learned that within ramsey plus it saves
marriages and so talking about marriages
marriages across the country could all
use a date night
right about now an evening uh to come
together and focus on what
matters most connection communication
and intimacy
intimacy maybe you've grown closer
together
through many uh challenges over the last
year or perhaps you've drifted
apart between homeschooling job loss or
financial stress but
guys check this out no matter what your
marriage looks like right now
for more unity and better communication
can be found
at our third annual specialist
valentine's edition
of money and marriage let me say that
again money and marriage is coming back
streaming live to your home on february
12th at 7 p.m
my dear friend our dear friend rachel
cruz and the
dr john de loni will guide you and your
spouse
through an unfor unforgettable night so
listen oliver passes for the money and
marriage slide stream on sale
right now for twenty dollars go to dave
ramsey.com
events to buy your tickets because hey
you need help
with your marriage all right you all
stay tuned we're gonna come back we're
gonna take a break
but listen we're gonna talk about your
life and your money we're here for you
pick up that phone triple 825-5225
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and
interior shutters with easy online
ordering free shipping
and a guaranteed perfect fit go to
blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Music]
so
welcome back to the dave ramsey show
where america hangs out to have a
conversation about
their life and money we're here for you
and we're excited to talk to you
so if you have not picked up that phone
yet i want you to
the number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five
again that's eight eight eight eight two
five five two two five we'd love to be
able to talk to you
about the things that are on your mind
uh we're gonna go back to the phone and
we're going to go
all the way to traverse city michigan we
got kate on the line kate how are you
i'm good chris thanks how are you oh
doing fantastic how can we help you
today
go ahead well my husband and i are both
millennials and we just went through a
major transition in our lives
we left we left corporate our corporate
jobs
in california we sold our home and we
became entrepreneurs and traveled in an
rv with our four kids for two and a half
years
are you serious yeah did you hear the
previous call
i i did and i was cracking up i was like
oh wow we're just like
we're right there with them we just did
that and now we've landed in michigan
okay so you have four kids as well
yes we do what are there eight what's
the answer
uh seven eight eight and ten wow
wow okay my goodness that's how
interesting okay
so you all traveled you did the thing uh
what baby step
are you all on we're investing
so we're debt-free um we paid off we
spent our 20's working
really hard and paying off around 68
thousand dollars in debt wow
hit our yeah then we hit our 30s
um and we're in corporate america with a
bunch of side hustles we were on like
career two or three between the two of
us
right and we've always been
entrepreneurs and knew that that was the
next step
but we had to get debt-free first we
just weren't willing to take that
risk to take on you know starting a
business with debt
okay um so when we sold our home we hit
the road and traveled for two years and
lived
below the poverty line because we could
travel for almost free
in our rv and stay at campgrounds and
whatnot and we built my husband's
business that way
while we were on the road and could kind
of learn some lessons without the
financial
consequences what kind of business is he
in what's a lot of work
he's a yeah he's an i.t engineer okay
gotcha
all right so you all landed it you
landed in michigan
what's your question that's right so i
am a stay-at-home mom
and i have a lot of experience and i can
go out and
double our income go out and get a job
and double our income
but we really value uh home education
raising our kids and focusing on that
our goal is financial independence and
we're just in this
kind of spot between a heart a rock and
a hard place trying to decide at what
point
do i take on additional work or do i
sacrifice
you know early retirement for staying
home with the kids and we're just trying
to find some advice and
and guidance and like how to make that
really difficult decision well
let me ask you this that's a great great
question because it shows you and your
husband are thinking forward
yeah um are are you homeschooling the
kids
yes okay all right so you are currently
homeschooling
what what is your your your plan on that
are you trying to get them to
middle school get them to high school
how far do you plan to home school
we are open to it as long as they are
willing it's a family decision
and so they've all expressed that they
might be interested in going to public
school or private school in high school
but until then they're really you know
convinced that they want to be home
which we love um but we're very
efficient
i like that you're trying to be
democratic i like that you let the
little kids raise their little hands and
everything and they feel like they
pulled the lever to vote
how does how does kate feel about it are
you enjoying homeschooling or no
i love it very much but coming from i'm
you know having a career and walking
away from that that's right
it's tough you know to walk away from
money it is and i'm going to tell you
something
just as you all navigate here here's how
i've got confidence in you what's your
husband's name
jason i've got confidence in kate and
jason
because you all traveled for two years
with four kids in an rv
okay you you all can do anything
and it is crappy you are scrappy and you
made sacrifices for the sake of what's
in the best interest of the family
and so here's the reality you and your
husband the kids i like that that you
include them and they hear their
feelings this is a decision for you and
your husband
and what i'm saying is is for you guys
to sit down and to look at the options
and the time
frame maybe this is something that you
say you know what
do we try a year of them in public
school
um while you work right but but but
it's a matter of talking through the
options first but then understanding the
time frame
and you guys making a collective
decision of this kate here's the thing
don't poor cement what i'm saying is
you're not making a final decision
that's going to have to stay that way
forever and ever i want you to think
like a scientist
just like you all tried scientists try
experiments all the time
and if the experiment fails they say the
experiment failed not them so
you guys did the experiment of the rv
and it worked
so now you think of what's the next
thing we're going to do for the sake of
the family's financial future
and the kids going to school for a year
or for a half a year to see how it goes
could be an experiment that you try i
like it i like it again and i just want
to commend y'all man
doing this is interesting seeing
millennials do this
um i i personally i like the fact that
you are asking your kids you know their
thoughts
i agree with hogan that that that the
decision is on you and your husband
um but make sure that you do include
your kids into the conversation because
it is their life too
um but i definitely want to include you
on that part but to answer your question
will will this lifestyle uh get you to
where you want to be
i think you and your husband have to
answer that question
you know hogan is known for saying
retirement is not
it's not about a particular age it's
about a particular number
you know how much money do you and your
husband want coming in on a monthly
basis
so that you all can retire inspired
retire with joy with peace
and i think that's the conversation you
and your husband need to sit down and
ask yourself today
like hey what is that number is it five
thousand ten thousand twenty thousand
whatever that number is
then y'all backtrack to what do we need
to be doing today
to get there yeah and kate here's the
deal how old are you all
uh i'm 34 and he's 35. okay now listen
here
okay you're young yeah you got a lot of
time
so even if you were trying to get the
kids up into middle school or into high
school
your earning potential is not dwindling
and you got an opportunity homeschooling
is serious work i
have no shadow of a doubt but for you to
brainstorm what is the goal
if the goal is spending time with the
kids in homeschooling okay it's great
but which one is the priority
and that can change you reserve the
right to make that adjustment
you could work from home and bring in
extra income now
right it would be like taking on two
jobs because you're already
you know doing the full-time job of of
of being the the teacher
and navigating with four kids so you and
your husband getting on the same page
beginning to set some goals as my
brother used to tell me be prayerful and
careful honey
uh about the choices you make in the
direction that you want to go
so thank you so much uh i really
appreciate you calling in
you know ao people ask me all the time
okay um is it too late for me
right or are we gonna be able to do it
and you're right i do tell them it's not
an age i don't care how old you are
if you've got breath in your lungs
you've got an opportunity to improve
you've got an opportunity to impact your
financial situation and positioning
right now but you got to make choices
and you got to make some decisions
to get moving in the right direction and
so if you're out there and you're
wondering well how much do i need to
retire
or what what do i got to do i've got a
free tool
called the retire inspired quotient the
riq
if you go to chrishogan360.com and click
on the
the the riq page it's going to walk you
through and help you figure out what you
want to do in retirement and what
how many years how much you have saved
it's going to give you this vision
and it's going to walk you through and
help you have more clarity and if you're
out there and you are
a millennial you can also send this link
to your parents
to help them as well nah and millennials
need to take this because i mean i
when you first came out with this hogan
i did it i sat down with my financial
advisors and said hey
uh how do we do this this is where i
want to be at and i got all the
information i think the younger you
are great man let's do it but it doesn't
matter if you're in your 50s
still take advantage of it you sure do
and also i want to tell you all uh
ao has got some recent episodes out i
already told you he talked to matthew
mcconaughey
and about his success but he's also got
one where he's having a discussion about
why you're not experienced happiness in
your life
uh this is ao he's got an on popular
online series called the table
as well as a podcast so you can go find
it wherever you
listen to podcasts go check him out but
also he's on the youtube
he's on there styling and profiling so
check him out there as well
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help get you there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
welcome back this is the dave ramsey
show uh
to blinds.com you get a 100 satisfaction
guarantee
means that if you mismeasure or you pick
the wrong color
they're going to remake your blinds for
free you're going to get free samples
you're going to get free shipping and
with the new promos that they run every
month
you'll save even more you want to use
the promo code
ramsey to get the best deal obviously
rules and restrictions apply ao what's
the question today today's question
comes from deshaun in utah he says what
is your opinion on self-defense
insurance
i am paying only 10.95 a month
and this gives me access to an on-call
lawyer if i ever have to use
my firearm for self-defense there is no
amount
cap on this so the plan is good for both
the criminal and for criminal and civil
trials in the event of having to defend
oneself is this
a wise type of insurance it's a waste of
money in my time
in my my opinion yeah deshawn i mean you
look at this
and you you want to ask yourself in that
kind of situation where you are dealing
with
the your life right uh because you know
obviously discharging a firearm and
having to defend yourself
uh you know any of those situations can
be 20 years or more in prison
uh if convicted and so this is your life
yeah i
i don't want a ten dollar attorney come
on i i don't want to deal with a a a cut
rate situation
now here's what i'm going to advise you
to do uh i'm not an insurance
professional my licenses are retired
uh but i would want you to sit down and
talk
uh to your insurance professional talk
uh and get some more details
you might even wanna have a consult with
an attorney on here uh
because you wanna dig into this and you
really wanna understand what it is
you're dealing with
unfortunately a lot of these programs
that i've looked into with these types
of insurances
desean they work as a reimbursement
program which means you foot the bill
and then they'll look to see if they
approve if they're going to reimburse
now i know don't you email me don't text
me and tell me
hogan no no these are paying upfront i
hear you
but you want to understand the magnitude
of what it is you're getting versus the
value
and so to me i think you're you're
better off uh engaging and and talking
with an attorney
to dig into the details to really
understand what this is i would not buy
this
and i'm point blank gonna tell you and
you're if i'm in your shoes i'm not
doing this
because i think it's going to give you a
false sense of security and it's just
not there
so that's the bottom line i agree all
right here we go getting back to the
phones
uh 888-825-5225 is the number to call
we'd love to be able to talk with you
all right we're going to oh i've been
here bend oregon
lindsay how are you hi i'm fine thanks
for taking my call
yes ma'am how can we help you today
well my husband and i recently
this past summer um moved to the united
states after
living and teaching overseas with our
family for 15 years
and we yeah we also had early retirement
in mind and yet
with covid and everything i ended up
getting a job here in beautiful bend
and we are now faced with trying to buy
a house
in an insane market and really just
wondering what to do
should we get a mortgage in this market
we do have savings and jobs
what kind of mortgage should we get we
were originally planning to
possibly pay cash in a different state
but that doesn't seem reasonable here in
binge okay
so tell me this what's yours household
income
it's about 140 000
okay and do you all have any debt right
now lindsay
we are debt-free and we are
significantly invested in
index funds okay very good what uh uh
how how much do you have saved for a
down payment on a home
well we currently have enough cash
probably
for twenty percent and we have about
close to three hundred thousand what
what's the average percent yeah what's
the average house in bend origin are you
looking for
uh lindsay yeah but the type of house
that we're looking for
is probably going to be seven to eight
hundred thousand at least
now what's the average house going for
in that city yeah
yeah i think the average is closer to
five
probably five hundred thousand it's gone
up uh 15
since even since we've been here since
july okay did you all
own homes when you were overseas no
we did not okay so this is where the
significant savings came from correct
yes so you want to know okay and you
keep saying in an expensive city
and the way you're saying bend oregon
you don't sound pleased about being
there
do you like it no we do love it
it's gorgeous it's beautiful we're just
uh surprised i think
by the housing market and of course kind
of in shell shock from covid
right no i can understand uh kovit has
brought many headaches and heartaches in
that process
but here's the thing i don't want you
all to relent
and just buy just because of that market
i think you all have shown having being
able to live overseas and
live and thrive for 15 years you all
have the ability to make decisions
you are masters of your domain to be
able to make a decision about where it
is you want to be
and if that's too expensive do you look
for jobs elsewhere in a cheaper market
right and i just i i don't want you to
sound like you're having to just give in
and do this
i want you all to be active participants
in your future
so is this where we want to be is this
where we want to buy because when you
buy the house then bend oregon
lindsay you also get to sell it
eventually and it's really important to
be aware
yeah yeah i agree and to answer your
question should you still buy
i think you got to sit down and do the
math if you put down 300 let's say on a
700 000
house you're going to be financing a 400
000 home with your net pay income
you're going to be right there around
the mortgage payment of 25
of your take-home pay so i think you and
your husband need to sit down and say
all right
when are we going do we really want to
be here do we really want to settle down
here for the next five years
uh two are we okay we're just doing
something right around seven hundred
thousand
if you go to eight hundred thousand with
a three hundred thousand dollar down
payment you are
stretching it a little bit but can you
afford
a seven hundred thousand dollar house
you can yeah i mean
and and again looking to go outside the
areas making a little bit of a drive is
always going to be cheaper
and so you just make decisions yeah for
yourself and i think sitting down
running the numbers
yeah obviously you can buy it when you
get ready to do a mortgage though
lindsey i want you to listen to me
lean in here lean in put your hair up by
the radio all right listen to me you're
only going to do a 15-year fixed-rate
mortgage
yep point-blank the the bank especially
out west
they do 40 and 50-year mortgages now
okay those are on
those are out there don't fall for that
stuff okay you're gonna go a 15-year fix
matter of fact i want you to get you and
your husband to pinky promise
you're only going to do a 15-year fix
that's the law
the bank don't even let them show you a
payment on 30 or 40 or anything else
15-year fix that's how you do it when
you get ready to buy
you need to look and see do can we see
ourselves living in this house
for three to five years if you can't
then don't do it
and it's okay for you all to continue to
sit on money
uh i'm proud of you for saving up money
the way that you have yes you all have
been
incredibly intentional uh throughout
this whole process
and continue to do it that way
communicating together working together
as a team
so it's important it's so good you know
hogan when i bought my first home i
moved
out to the country and uh while it was
i can afford it i would definitely say
if i had to go back i wouldn't do it
again
because i had a long drive i was out
there by myself and
just it just wasn't right right so i
think when you're looking for a home
don't just do it just to save money but
find a place where yeah you can get a
good price but then you also can say
i like pulling into this place yes
and that's so important it is important
man and you won't understand what's my
commute
where am i am i around things i want to
be around
and again you make a sacrifice but i'm
with you
um and and we all live and learn the
first one i bought this house was just
too big yeah
right and it wasn't necessarily we're in
an area i wanted to be in yeah
uh so you just live and learn and i
think the good the
here's what i would tell people if
you're going house shopping get a real
estate agent that you trust
and only go look at properties in your
price range no i'm serious
don't go don't let that realtor tell you
oh this one's 60 grand out of your range
but we can talk them down
no you won't and you're gonna walk in
there and feel like cinderella
because you found this house that you
love you're gonna fall in love with it
and you're gonna jack up your budget
i'm telling you don't even go look i
told my real estate agent you pull up to
a house that i'm not in my price range
i'm gonna fire you on the spot
and she knew i was serious because i'd
already done that stupid one time before
don't look at me like that ao i'll put
you in a headlock
i don't worry about you all right y'all
listen this is the dave ramsey show we
will be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the show uh i am chris
hogan and
co-hosting along with me is anthony
o'neill we've had a blast talking with
you
uh today's scripture comes from acts 20
35
in all things i have shown you that by
working hard in this way
we must help the weak and remember the
words of the lord jesus
how he himself said it is more blessed
to give
than to receive today's quote
great things are done by a series of
small things brought together
by vincent van gogh that's so good
we got an opportunity people we can make
a decision about our future
and we we get a chance to choose and do
all in the same moment we don't need a
permission slip we don't anybody decided
to give us permission to have our dreams
or to give the effort to chase them down
and i want to encourage you to make sure
that you are chasing
something down something that's
worthwhile for you as well as your
financial future
all right we're gonna get back to the
phones uh we got thomas on the line
thomas how can i help you hi thanks for
taking my call
just a quick question that i had for you
um currently we are renting a basement
apartment
um from a family friend um and they
today have just told us that they are
planning on selling the house and moving
out
um our contract is due to expire um
about in july and they're planning on
moving out in june
so my wife and i today we've been
looking at some apartment
and we saw that we would end up be
paying around
400 to 500 more at
um any other apartments okay um so we
could
so we paying around twelve hundred
dollars um and i've looked up some of
the houses and i don't know if we
try to stretch ourselves to buy a house
i just don't like the concept and the
idea
of paying rent and having it go nowhere
no i understand now thomas you how much
are you paying for this basement
apartment right now
so because the family friend they're
only charging us 850 dollars
okay and you know if you were out
somewhere else
it would be closer probably to 1200
yeah okay all right so let's be honest
first and foremost you got the shock
of paying an additional 400 dollars
correct
correct okay let's just be real i'm here
i hear you
and you're saying okay do we if if we
got to get out
what do we do do we keep renting or do
we buy all right what
are you familiar with the baby steps
i am currently we're on baby step three
okay good so
you are do you're working to get your
emergency fund in place
exactly yeah me and my wife both are
working all right good
uh so how much income do you all make a
year
um yeah so we combine make about um 35
000
a year both of you yeah
yeah what are you all doing my wife's in
school my wife's in school and so she
only works
minimal minimal hours okay um and then
i'm pretty young i'm only 20 years old
and i i just work at i'm a supervisor at
a call center
thomas and i all mean to cut off hogan
but you said it earlier and i think you
already know the answer you said should
we stretch ourselves
and i just i mean this is an easy
conversation no
you shouldn't stress yourself at all if
you're saying hey should we stretch
ourselves
because we want to pay if we're going to
pay this amount of money we want to own
no you are not ready to purchase at home
young man okay
and i just want to be real with you go
rent something or
um yeah go rent okay you're not ready to
purchase a home
and i just want to say that i i was
screaming inside of me like no no
no but uh you know i know hogan will
walk you through some other stuff but
i just want to tell you no bro and you
need to rock with me on my show cause i
help you get into your home real quick
in about a year two years
yeah i mean i want you to stretch
yourself i want you to stretch your
effort i want you to stretch your dreams
and i want you to stretch your reality
but no i don't want you to stretch
yourself financially i agree 100
with anthony uh you know you guys are
not in a position yet you got to get
this
this this emergency fund in place 2020
taught us
2020 taught us the emergency fund is
necessary yeah and so now what you want
to do is get that in place then start
saving
uh but it does stink that you guys had a
situation and now it's adjusting on you
and your budget's gonna have to change
because you're paying 400 more
right i get that but i'm with you
anthony you're gonna keep renting and a
matter of fact i'm probably going to
move
out into an area if i can get cheaper
rent and make a little bit more of a
drive
uh you got to do that kind of little
calculation but no
not just because i tell anthony i tell
people all the time i don't care how low
mortgage rates are
right if you're not ready you're not
ready no you're not and i tell this to
all young people especially millennials
there's this huge wave of two things
they either want to
get a house or go buy a duplex and run
out the other side like no listen
do the priorities okay the baby steps
work for
a reason okay do not look at just what
you're paying out monthly
look at everything you have to pay for
your down payment your monthly payment
your water bill will go up your
electricity bill is going to go up
now you're held liable you got to be
responsible for everything that goes
wrong in the house that's right so it's
not
just your mortgage payment young people
hear me clearly now i'm frustrated so
hogan you got to sit here and calm down
for a little bit
cause i'm i'm upset i'm like oh i'm
talking situation
i mean young people are so frustrating
to me right now because like hey
i want to get a house i want to get a
mortgage i want to have passive income
no
what you need to do is get a foundation
and then when you get a foundation
then let's talk about how do we build on
top of that foundation and the
foundation the first three baby steps
get a thousand dollars pay off all your
consumer debt
get an emergency fund then 3b get a down
payment so you can get into a house
don't call into this show again asking
can we break some rules
because it's gonna be a simple answer no
all right see this
okay ao needs a nap okay
he needs a nap he's he's getting tricey
he's get a little feisty
and that's fine it's fine man i got you
i got you see it's good that i'm the
calm one
everybody thinks that i'm the feisty one
no but seriously you know you don't want
to let the situation out there determine
your reality and it's a matter of just
being real and i think
it's great to have dreams i think it's
great to have goals
but what you don't want to do trust me
i've done this stupid
where you outreach your situation just
because you want it really bad
where you stretch yourself a little bit
too far financially just because you
just had to have it
and it's not worth it again take a deep
breath
be clear and people stop doing ish
don't do the ramsay plus ish do it
okay dig into it follow these baby steps
it's gonna change your world
when we try to do eight things at a time
we're ineffective in
seven of them when we focus on one thing
at a time
we can make some changes happen and i'm
gonna tell you something you start
believing
and seeing results things change and so
we can help you get there so
get plugged in and know exactly what's
going on all right let's
let's try to take another call i've got
kimberly on the line all right kimberly
quickly let us know your question hi
my question is i am currently
disabled i get social security a set
income
i have student a student loan that's
about
12 000 it's on deferment right now
i applied for bone forgiveness
but i don't know i haven't got a final
answer
if that's the best route or if i should
just pay the minimum
well i mean first of all if you applied
for it i i want you to follow up
right correct so we can we're not going
to speculate on on what's the best route
it you getting the information is going
to help you uh so i want you
to your job is to follow up you're
calling and calling until you get an
answer
ao you're the student loan expert talk
to her yeah kimberly here's the thing
i agree with hogan follow up with it i
mean right now with congress and in the
new
uh system that we have in place um i
honestly don't know what this student
loan forgiveness thing is going to look
like
but until you get a response i do want
you to be making as many minimum
payments i would not minimum
but i do want you to be throwing
something after it as much as possible
now you say you're on disability how
much disability are you getting right
now
so every month i get six hundred and
twenty one it just went up for
california
yeah um to six hundred and twenty nine
thousand two dollars so how are you
covering
29 a month and real quick how are you
covering your four walls like your
housing and your utility stuff
is that taken care of my husband yes my
husband works full-time
okay sounds good so then yes i want you
to take that money start attacking your
student loans
and then keep following up to see what's
going to happen with your student loan
forgiveness
and in the meantime attack that and what
i'm going to do is stay on the line
i'm gonna have kelly send you a copy of
my book destroy your student loan
uh book it's only 80 pages long it'll
take you maybe
an hour to read it it'll take you 20
minutes to listen to me
um uh via um audio but we're going to
get that book to you all right
fantastic thank you all all right listen
we want to thank all the callers for
taking the time to call
in i want to thank producer james child
and associate producer kelly daniel
and also thank you everyone and ao great
job today buddy hey thank you
appreciate you all listen until next
time stay safe and stay focused
you can do this
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you